- Un climat de peur s'est
installé dans la ville de
Juarez. Aux portes des États-
Unis, deux gangs rivaux
se livrent un combat d'une
violence sans précédent.
Tout a commencé par un
affrontement dans cette prison.c
sont sans nouvelle des détenus.
"On est chanceux d'être partis
en vie, dit la mère d'un
prisonnier. À l'intérieur des
enfants pleuraient, des
personnes âgées mourraient.
Ils ont lancé des bombes,
des cocktails molotov,
tout brûlait."
Les attaques se déplacent dans
la ville. Les cartels incendient
des véhicules, ouvrent le feu
sur des magasins et tirent sans
pitié sur des innocents.
Dans ce restaurant de pizza,
quatre employés d'une station
de radio ont été tués.
"Ce n'était pas arrivé avant
et on espère que cela ne se
reproduise plus. Des personnes
innoncentes ont été attaquées
en représailles",
le président du Mexique.
La garde nationale est déployée
sur le terrain. 600 militaires
arrivent pour renforcer
la sécurité dans la ville.
Les autorités ont mis la main
sur six membres présumés du gang
local Mexicles. Los Chapos,
le grouple grouple grouple grous
avec le cartel de l'ancien baron
de la drogue, El Chapo,
emprisonné aux États-Unis.
"Nous n'arrêterons pas
jusqu'à ce que l'ordre soit
rétablie et nous utiliserons
toutes les ressources
nécessai parvenir",
avertit Roberto Fierro,
procureur de l'État de
Chihuahua.
La vague de violence a fait
11 victimes à Juarez,
majoritairement des civils.
Plus à l'ouest, la guerre de la
drogue au Mexique terrorise
aussi les résident de Tijuana,
Mexicali et Rosarito, près de la
frontière américaine.
Ici Charlotte Dumoulin,
Radio-C